[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal est
d'informations locales nous sommes le 27
octobre et parmi les sujets que nous
allons aborder aujourd'hui la conférence
de frédéric égal c'est le directeur
général du refuge l'association de lutte
contre l'homophobie entend accompagner
les intervenants du secteur social à
mieux comprendre le public lgbt
lorsqu'il est en difficulté
le soutien scolaire se porte bien que ce
soit en ligne ou lors de cours
particuliers avec des enseignants de
nombreux parents veulent profiter des
vacances pour remettre leurs enfants à
niveau et puis les vacances c'est aussi
fait avant tout pour s'amuser à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet les
cowboys et les indiens vous le voyez
sont à l'honneur
et cette information pourrait débuter le
meurtrier de cédric jaussaud 38 ans chef
de la police municipale de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines elle vient est
d'être condamné à 25 ans de réclusion
criminelle assortis d'une période de
sûreté est de 16 ans par la cour
d'assises des yvelines à versailles le
20 novembre 2012 il avait égorgé au
cutter dans son bureau celui qui était
devenu le nouveau compagnon de son ex
femme il affirmé devant la cour être
devenu fou en apprenant le déménagement
prochain est du couple dans l'actualité
également nous en parler on titre
l'association le refuge créée en 2003
pour lutter contre l'isolément des
jeunes homosexuels à organiser une
conférence à maurepas hier soir une
trentaine de personnes a pu échanger sur
la reconnaissance de l'homosexualité en
france avec elle est responsable de
cette structure le reportage de michael
almy d'euros
parler de l'isolément des homosexuels
dans la société c'était l'objectif de la
conférence débat organisée par
l'association lo refuse ce mercredi à
maurepas la structure combat ce
phénomène depuis sa création à
montpellier en 2003 en implantant des
structures d'accueil dans 16 villes en
france on est dernier on a hébergé plus
de 196 personnes accompagne plus de 800
jeunes qui nous ont contactés par la
médaille d'argent du refuge on a eu à
peu près 1000 1800 rappelle solène
urgence du refuge pour ce sujet là puis
à les suivre aussi doit cesser nos
phobies qui chaque année sont aussi
terrible parce qu'ils montrent la
réalité est encore qu'une partie de la
réalité c'est les gens qui ont fait la
démarche de faire de porter plainte ou
autre et il ya encore toute la partie
qui ne porte pas plainte ou la partie
qui le vise en silence pour la première
fois une conférence organisée par le
refuge s'est tenue sur le sol yvelinois
notre raid est pouvoir l'étendre pas
simplement grande ville au premier
propose mais aussi de le faire dans des
endroits un peu plus reculée
géographiquement et puis c'est bien
intéresser un maximum de personnes et
plus éco si les gens qui sont pas
forcément sur des grands axes puisse
aussi en bénéficier puisse aussi
simplement y participer la session a
débuté par un échange sur l'histoire de
l'homosexualité les intervenants ont
ensuite diffusé le film carte blanche de
sonia rolland au total une trentaine de
personnes a participé à ce rendez vous
c'est vivant et très intéressant le
niveau des dates des lois et cetera du
nom de pays qui sont encore beaucoup
fermé par rapport à ça donc c'est
intéressant certaines personnes peuvent
parler de choses qu'ils ne connaissent
pas et du coup ces interventions peuvent
permet justement de plus ce seront
sensibilisés à ça aucune structure
d'accueil le refus jeu sera implanté
dans les yvelines dans les prochains
mois le centre le plus proche est situé
à paris rue des ligues dans le 12e
arrondissement
le député ps benoît hamon candidat à la
primaire de la gauche estime que la
vraie gangrène des quartiers c'est
aujourd'hui l'économie duhai cannabis et
il plaide pour la légalisation afin de
dit il tu essaies trafic cette
proposition elle ne manque pas de faire
débat écouter d'ailleurs cet extrait de
notre prochain un café politique sur
téléphiles est nicolas à dainville et
lui les républicains à saint quentin
était face à sandrine grand gang élus du
parti socialiste première secrétaire
fédérale dans le département tels
l'événement vous garder en mémoire sur
l'actualité des quinze derniers jours en
ce qui vous concerne
alors moi je vais sortir un jeu pas d'un
événement un peu personnel qui va
particulièrement choqué marqué c'est la
proposition de benoît hamon de légaliser
le cannabis alors on le voit dans
beaucoup de quartiers c'est un drame
pour beaucoup de familles avec des
enfants et les bus les anciens du script
sion je vais leur préciser exactement
avec des enfants qui décrochent qui ont
des pertes des troubles de la mémoire de
la concentration à cause du cannabis et
je trouve que c'est un message de
laxisme assez terrifiant envoyé aux
dealers et autres trafiquants on baisse
les bras on légalise et au lieu de
lutter contre ce trafic qui fait
beaucoup de ravages dans nos familles
donc sa main quelque chose qui m'a
particulièrement marqué sans les
vendeurs j'imagine que vous allez
répondre
aurait dû attraper c'est le message
envoyé aux dealers c'est justement de
dire ben vous n'avez plus votre place
dans les quartiers et donc on est dans
le tout répressif la sueur sur le
cannabis je pense qu'il est temps
d'imaginer autre chose il ya beaucoup
d'études qui montrent qu'il ya peut-être
d'autres solutions
l'intégralité de ce café politique sera
à découvrir sur notre antenne à partir
de samedi en replay également sur notre
site internet et puis vous l'avez aperçu
autres invités de cette émission
françois simeoni le président du fn 78
après six années de baisse la
vaccination contre la grippe saisonnière
et pour la première fois repartis à la
hausse l'an dernier selon des chiffres
fournis par l'assurance maladie le taux
de couverture vaccinale des 11 millions
de français invités à se faire vacciner
gratuitement contre la grippe a atteint
les 40 8,3 pour cent contre 46,1 % en
2014 le point avec ce reportage de
nicolas landry
les yvelines bon élève de la couverture
vaccinale contre la grippe sur la saison
dernière
46 5% des personnes invitées à se faire
vacciner ont eu recours à la vaccination
contre 44,5 pour cent en 2014 2015 une
progression causés par les mesures des
pouvoirs publics tant que l'assurance
maladie a dressé dans les yvelines ah
bon de prise en charge à 245 milles
personnes
pour les inciter à se faire vacciner en
retirant gratuitement le vaccin dans les
pharmacies à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la couverture vaccinale a reculé cinq
communes ont un taux de couverture en
dessous de 45 % pour ces situations la
cpam des yvelines
a veille avec la rs et les acteurs
locaux avec comme objectif travailler
sur un diagnostic
départementale donc sur les vaccinations
notamment la vaccination grippe mais
aussi les vaccinations petite enfance et
sur la base d'un diagnostic
cartographier de monter de mettre en
place un plan d'action départemental
pour améliorer la couverture vaccinale
en 2015 2016 près de 2500 consultation
sos médecins ont été causés par des
syndromes grippaux dans les yvelines
selon les données de santé publique
france contre environ 3000 en 2014 2015
il faut savoir que le plus souvent les
symptômes de la grippe apparaissent à
trois jours après la contamination est
forte fièvre fatigue courbatures maux de
tête sont les premiers signes de la
maladie si pour la plupart des personnes
la guérison se fait spontanément pour
d'autres la grippe peut se compliquer et
entraîné une hospitalisation en
réanimation voir un décès les personnes
âgées de 65 ans et plus et celles
présentant des facteurs de risque qu'il
s'agisse d'une grossesse d'une maladie
chronique ça peut être affections
respiratoires cardiovasculaires
immunodépression diabète et les
personnes obèses voilà pour les
principaux sujets à risque de avec se
laver les mains et se protéger la bouche
en cas d'éternuement ou de toux sont
d'autres moyens de lutter contre la
propagation du virus de la grippe
vie locale est le mail du quartier des
saules à guyancourt qui doit
prochainement faire l'objet d'une
rénovation aujourd'hui une instance est
une association s'est invité dans la
discussion c'est la sauce régale c'est
son nom elle demande une concertation
publique elle souhaite qu'un jardin
éco-responsable puisse voir le jour et
camille lambert et osman vendeurs des
pour le commentaire à l'occasion du
réaménagement du my des soldes asos
régal se mobilisent pour faire entendre
sa voix l'association qui fait la
promotion de l'agriculture urbaine
souhaite que la mairie créé des jardins
partagés desjardins qui selon eux
permettront d'améliorer la vie au
quartier des sceaux
mais nous on aimerait bien implantée
dans deux parades a par endroits des
endroits des potagers qu'on puisse
surtout en fait cultiver avec les gens
parce que notre idée c'est à la fois de
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique c'est-à-dire de proposer des
légumes locaux accessibles aux gens
avant tout c'est pour leur propre
consommation est aussi retrouver du lien
social dans un univers un petit peu
anonyme comme celui ci on aimerait un
peu comme dans les villages quoi une
trentaine de personnes s'étaient
rassemblés pour l'événement et ils sont
séduits par cette idée de jardins
partagés j'ai signé le registre j'ai mis
un petit mot en fait j'aimerais bien
apporter des bases dans lesquels on
pourrait planter des légumes des petites
choses des fraisiers des choses simples
à cultiver ensemble et à partager et
puis aussi pourquoi pas des herbes
aromatiques chose qui pousse tout seul
très souvent très simples à cultiver moi
j'adore jardiner alors que j'ai pas de
jardin et j'adorais aussi des arbres ce
métier l'association du jardin partagé
de guyancourt sem qui peut a aussi
participé à l'événement le my des saules
va entamer sa transformation à partir de
l'été prochain
alors que certains en profitent des
vacances pour se reposer d'autres
préfèrent réviser leurs cours de la
primaire au lycée le soutien scolaire
s'organise notamment à saint quentin en
yvelines l'engouement des parents ne
faiblit pas et pourtant le conseil
national d'évaluation du système
scolaire le juge peu efficace ce même
rapport souligne également que notre
système scolaire serait l'un des plus
inégalitaires des pays les plus
développés camille lambert
le rouge et le noir de stendhal une
oeuvre incontournable pour ces lycéens
karen est en terminale elle a choisi de
s'inscrire aux cours de l'association
archimède pour réviser la littérature
pendant les vacances
j'ai pas eue avec les nerfs du coup bas
forget est prématuré de prendre des
cours parce que je repasse le français
et du coup impérativement que françois
haut niveau en plus c'est des petits
groupes cd groupe de 3 4 11 pas des
groupes de vins comme en classe
c'est archi bénéfique le soutien
scolaire est assuré par des professeurs
des mathématiques aux langues vivantes
depuis 1990 l'équipe propose un suivi
hebdomadaire ou des stages vacances
comme ils i pour la toussaint une
quarantaine d'élèves se sont inscrits
tous niveaux confondus donc il faut en
gros toute la matinée ça peut être notre
français ça peut être maths physique ça
peut être français anglais enfin on
essaie de d'avoir une organisation aussi
très souple ça toujours été depuis le
départ de travailler avec sa confort en
fonction de ce qu'il est c'est-à-dire de
ses besoins de le prendre là où il en
est aujourd'hui ces lacunes c'est et de
de construire à partir de sa dynamique
propre là j'ai pris anglais et avancent
pendant les vacances et les grandes
vacances j'avais pris français enlevés
aussi ça permet de réviser pendant les
vacances pour comme ça quand tu quand on
reprend ni cours et
on n'oublie pas qu'on avait fait avant à
willencourt c'est le numérique qui est
privilégié la ville mis sur les
révisions en ligne pour ses élèves du cp
à la terminale le site et l'encours en
ligne propose des cours et des exercices
dans chaque matière un service offert
gratuitement par la mairie depuis 2010
sur présentation d'un justificatif de
domicile ça le rend beaucoup plus
autonome
deuxièmement ça développe sa créativité
et surtout et surtout ça développe sa
confiance en lui-même vous avez votre
progression par exemple pas si vous avez
fait
10 exercices en histoire ou si vous en
avez fait 50 il faut en faire 50 vous
avez la montée vous allez voir si vous
avez réussi si vous avez échoué vous
pouvez recommencer le court au total
3000 élèves élan courtois sont abonnés à
ce dispositif le soutien en ligne ou en
direct avec des professeurs peut être un
moyen de lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire chaque année 140 mille élèves
quittent le système scolaire sans aucun
diplôme
on quitte le scooter le soutien scolaire
pour parler des vacances à présent la
bergerie nationale vite à l'heure du far
west depuis quelques jours cowboys et
indiens ont envahi le domaine plus de
400 visiteurs sont présents c'est la
cinquième année cette opération est
organisée mélanie poker patrick jacques
de dixmude pour les images
les indiens n'ont qu'à bien se tenir le
cow boy solitaire ne l'est plus depuis
lundi lucky luke s'est trouvé des
acolytes à la bergerie nationale
le far west est à rambouillet
j'ai bien tiré là là bas j'aime bien
tirer à l'arc je trouve que toutes les
activités sont faites avec peu de moyens
et mais très bien avec plein d'idées
pour les enfants c'est génial nature il
ya les animaux il ya les petits ateliers
ludiques c'est vrai que voilà des petits
ateliers où sont fabriqués
sa petite hache ou que c'est vrai que
pour ça les enfants sont friandes ça
c'est sympa les infos l'air de bien
s'amuser
c'est la cinquième année pour ces
vacances cowboys et indiens le point
culminant la fameuse attaque de la
diligence près de 400 visiteurs se
prennent au jeu
c'est une accumulation de petits jeux
qui fait qu'on a l'impression que c'est
un spectacle où les palais les parents
sont spectateurs et les enfants
deviennent acteurs où on va essayer de
de se battre contre les indiens de façon
pacifique en criant plus fort en faisant
un tir à la corde en dansant la country
dans le concours de tir à la corde ce
sont les indiens qui ont gagné mais les
cowboys se sont promis ils prendront
leur revanche ils ont jusqu'au 2
novembre pour relever le défi
[Applaudissements]
merci de nous avoir suivi le journal
revient à lundi aux horaires habituels
demain vendredi vous avez rendez vous
avec nicolas kirillovitch pour le 7 8 l
hebdo très bonne soirée
[Musique]